alivari is a town of five thousand about
an hour and a half drive from athens
most of the people there live from
fishing
it's the same in amarintos a few
kilometers away
in both everyone is presently talking
about one thing will greece remain in
the eurozone
the situation has triggered a run on
local atms here at least they're still
paying out
am i going to get my money or has the
bank already blocked everything
we have nothing left to lose
whether it's the drama or the euro it's
all the same
the politicians have sold us out
the statue of a minor on oliveria's
central square recalls the past but the
coal-fired power plant here shut down
long ago the message on the banner reads
no deal against the people of greece
opinions are sharply divided some say
the referendum won't change anything
others expect big things from the syriza
government or european partners
pensioners meet up in a cafe every day
to talk
all are disappointed
that salaries would be increased again
it brings in just enough for her to get
by
there are few people of her generation
left in alaveri
she's long since stopped expecting
anything from athens or brussels
nothing will change
it doesn't matter whether we vote yes or
no in the referendum nothing will change
i just don't trust the politicians
anymore
farmers from surrounding areas offer
their produce at the market
business isn't as good as it used to be
because many people in aloe vera have
lost their jobs
five thousand people once worked at the
power plant
the company that runs it now employs
just two hundred
the elderly people at the market think
the situation has grown dire
at this moment is like titanic
like titanic
in the midnight
in the icebergs
and start
to sunk
a closed factory just opposite the
town's beach
aliberry was never a big tourist
destination but greeks at least
sometimes used to come and spend a few
days now they just don't have the money
only the pensioners remain
this man has to sell his house though he
won't get much for it he hasn't even
heard about the referendum
we have to watch our money
the fishermen set out in their boats at
five in the morning even though it's
grown hard to sell their catch
there are few customers
politics and the referendum seem very
far away
i'm not sitting in front of the
television here
we work all day then i go home and do
the housework
i don't have an opinion on the
referendum some say it's good some say
it's bad to be honest i have no idea
few people populate the restaurants and
cafes on the town's promenade
but despite the crisis the greeks have
maintained their pride
i don't want to go back to the drachma
i want to stay in the euro
we have to remain strong
greece forever
this week will determine the future for
aliberi and for greece